heute schon wollen sich hier drin
[Musik]
eigentlich eine stimme langweilige sache
außer einer afd kandidatinnen tritt in
einem linksgrünen versifften kita wie
sibylle schmidt hallo
suchen sie die gefahr nein warum kennt
man sie in kreuzberg eigentlich als afd
kandidaten kennen sie frau schmidt nein
nicht wirklich
würden sie frau schmidt wählen würden
nicht willkommen zurück
vielleicht haben sie die gegenargumente
und können für die fdp werben
du brauchst keine angst haben in dieser
partei sind menschen aus allen anderen
parteien die haben sich da
zusammengefunden und momentan etwas
gegen die unkontrollierte
masseneinwanderung zu machen habe ich ja
jetzt schon mal kurz wiederholen auf
meine sprache der zulu sprache das ist
die damals wollte mir jetzt gerade
erklären das was für die afg sprich als
da wären dass dieser schneiden die
gitter zu den kommunisten schweinen
kreuzberg kapitalismus schweine system
was fällt der afd dazu ein
es ist ein kann der buchladen hier
sollen sie ihre meinung äußern
berührt mich nicht so wird auch mal
reingehen fragen die sie kennen heute
schon gar nicht drin
wir gehen jetzt mal zusammen zu den
grünen
das gibt es wind ordentlich zunder hallo
ich bin der karten und das ist die frau
schmidt von der afg und ein paar kurze
mit euch ein bisschen sprechen ist es
möglich wenn die hälfte kommt bringen
die grünen erst mal ihre plagen in
sicherheit und produziert bei ihr auch
so
europa muss immer auf einem stuhl sitzen
ist immer so mit es gibt ja zwischen den
grünen und der fdp gemeinsamkeiten als
man gemeinhin annimmt sind ja auch
gegend tipp oder die heftig denke schon
also wir haben wahrscheinlich
gemeinsamkeiten das lässt sich ja gar
nicht leugnen also wahrscheinlich essen
auch mit der afg manchmal butter brot
auch mal elegant mal nikolic mehr als
vier zähler trennen wurde unchristlich
die haben das wie gesagt dann wird
bezahlt eben kein heißhunger wenn sie
das kind das ist nicht richtig denn
deutlich informieren
zusagen muss man prozessen oder ich
nehme gerne es sind lauter spannende
fragen die mich wirklich brennend
interessieren man sieht sind nämlich gar
nicht auf der straße warum haben sie
eigentlich kandidaten auf ihrer
landesliste die verbindung ins
rechtsextreme spektrum haben gute
schreibe warum ist nicht eingefallen wie
beispielsweise welches speziell china
nicht sehen dass ich ein spezialthema
china
zweibrücken der nacht nicht nerven ich
denke antworten auf die frage wenn ich
ihnen was zu essen holen leckeren burger
beispielsweise sie wissen doch hier
vegan verspielt und links versetzt
zwei dinge haben sich für mich heute
bestätigt die ard hat keinen plan und
die grünen können nicht grillen